good morning and good evening to you all
um my name is dr michael risley and i
lead product development activities at
your gene health
i'll be talking today about clarigene a
pandemic diagnostic
story and to begin with i'll give a
brief overview of the content of this
presentation so i'll introduce your gene
health
including what we have to offer our
expertise and
the company vision and i'll move on to
why
and how your gene health engaged in the
kobit 19 diagnostic space
followed by the challenges uh involved
in developing a
kovid 19 diagnostic product during the
height of the pandemic
um i'll take through i'll take you
through design choices covering the why
and how decisions were made
and as as your gene health is in both
the product and
service business i'll describe
transferring the civd
product into the service lab um and then
go through the topic of
of sars cov2 variants and what this
actually means for diagnostic
products and that are designed to detect
this virus
so eugene health is an international
molecular diagnostics
group which develops and commercializes
genetic products and services the group
works in partnership with global leaders
in dna
technology to advance diagnostic science
and primarily we develop manufacture
and commercialize molecular diagnostic
solutions for reproductive health
and precision medicine and now
infectious diseases
flagship products include non-invasive
prenatal tests that's nipt
the downs syndrome and other genetic
disorders
cystic fibrosis screening tests invasive
rapid aneuploidy tests and a recent
extension into the oncology space with
dpyd genotyping and braddock's core your
gene health is about
helping patients and from supporting
diagnosis of diseases apart newborn
screening to
providing women with information to aid
in the decision-making during pregnancy
and to helping prevent unnecessary
deaths due to
toxicity and cancer treatments what
we're really there to do is aim to
enable scientific advances to positively
impact
human health going back
just over a year um here in the uk just
as in much of the world
there were clear signs that we were
moving quickly towards a national
lockdown
and that could dramatically impact how
the business would operate and function
with the potential for people to be
unable to come into work
to prepare ourselves in the days
preceding the national lot down in the
uk
we stress tested the business with a
with a fire drill
and having only people who must come on
site
be on site to come actually come into
the facilities fortunately what we found
was a great resilience
um and we were able to operate very
close to normal productivity
so when the lockdown hit we were
prepared with your gene health being in
the medical device supply chain
it was it also meant that people who
needed to be on site
to manufacture products for example and
were eligible to do so
so as we were able to operate a near
normal near normally across the business
um across much of the business and with
the with this company vision
in mind you know aiming to positively
impact human health
it meant that we were able and willing
to involve ourselves in efforts to
contain the virus and at this point
while we had
extensive experience in developing in
vitro diagnostic products
infectious disease testing is not
something that we had any real
experience of
however your genes experience in the
manufacture of those ivd products
and to the required quality standards
meant that we could
whether the product operations team
could support the manufacturing scale-up
of sales co-2 diagnostic products
that have been designed and developed by
other businesses
so we went into partnership and we
utilized the product operations
teams expertise and the facilities to
make significant numbers of
diagnostic tests on behalf of our
partners
with supporting activities through this
manufacture of third-party
designed and developed products
progressing successfully
the next step was to look at whether
your gene
health could and should develop a
diagnostic product in-house
and to decide on whether to do so we
performed a rapid evaluation with the
aim of getting a handle on
how the fast-moving situation was likely
to play out
and with each passing day it seemed the
message seems clearer that the long-term
solution to getting out of the pandemic
will be through the development of
effective vaccines
and but that would take some time and
until then mass testing
would be the key to allowing societies
to exit from lockdowns and gain
at least some degree of normality by
identifying those who have been infected
with the
zarzakov2 virus and enabling their
isolation from the community
to reduce the risk of onward spread
of the different types of testing
antibody testing was both
outside of your gene's expertise and
would only show whether people have been
infected at some point in the past
while antigen tests were also not in our
sweet spot
plus there was much debate around the
accuracy and utility of this type of
test at the time
looking at the core technical expertise
within the business and the likelihood
that mass
testing and mass nucleic acid testing
was a likely scenario for many countries
developing a product designed to present
to detect the presence of viral nucleic
acid
seems the obvious choice
and any business will always look to
develop
products in the short time frame as
possible to deliver these to market
and help people help the patients while
also driving company growth
developing a diagnostic during a
pandemic really took this need for speed
off the scale
our standard process of entering an idea
into a gateway funnel
a gateway innovation funnel building the
business case
developing that deep understanding of
the market
by a voice of customer analysis as well
as planning to resource and prioritize
activities went from a time frame of
months to
days and fast tracking decisions and
planning
we then pulled a team together from
across departments to figure out how to
quickly deliver
a sars cup to diagnostic quickly and
effectively
with this cross-functional team a new
development needed to be pulled together
without also without disrupting key
activities because we still had a number
of key projects going on at the time
and another and so the team had to be
very smart
and while we had quickly moved to remote
working for most of the business
um for the most part this had allowed a
continuation of
existing activities that people were
already familiar with what would
need to be done and what was coming next
um for the new product developments this
this covered test
the team needed to be formed from new
while not being located together so
um a new project team formed almost
entirely over ms teams
and at this time we also had people
working at home with
children and working very unusual hours
while others were
able to access the lab and would be more
working your typical
hours that you'd expect and somehow
needed to blend this together and make
it work
and the product was also to be developed
as a civd
so that meant absolutely no shortcuts uh
allowable on any quality standards so
all the usual requirements
for an ivd were to be followed while at
the same time
aiming to reduce the time frame from
development for a development project
from perhaps up to a year down to just a
few months
so we quickly discovered that
expectations in regards to
the supply of materials needed to be
reset
with the pandemic being quite literally
global
the whole world realized it would need
these diagnostic tests
the diagnostic industry was itself
continuing as usual
to a greater or lesser degree and with
an additional huge demand
placed on materials for those used in
relation to development and diagnostic
use of stars cover ii
products the the global supply chain for
molecular diagnostics has a
finite capacity as with any other
industry
and so a consequence of putting these
two factors together was a huge
strain on the global supply chain uh
tate which would take lead times
potentially from
days or weeks to weeks or months and
enzymes
buffers oligonucleotides plastics were
all in demand like you know
we've just never seen before
in the uk um the government also put out
a call
to develop diagnostic tests that didn't
use the same supply chain
this led us to look at a range of
suppliers and also to review raw
materials we may not have otherwise
looked at such as
perhaps a different or more bespoke
selection of fluorophores
we also had to mitigate risks so while
being conscious not to add to the burden
of the supply chain um such as ordering
oligonucleotides from more than one
source but we needed to order
and make sure we had quantities that
were aligned to their project team's
needs
our procurement and logistics teams
worked closely with existing and new
suppliers
to ensure we had just enough of what we
needed and when we needed it
reliable supply is a key for any
business uh even more so at times when
the
when this supply was so constrained
as far as possible a part of the
strategy was to avoid using the same
supply chains coming online
via mass test in the uk and elsewhere
where we had had visibility
and to develop and validate a sr's of
two diagnostic also as with any other
diagnostic
also required access to clinical samples
with known provenance
and it probably sounds a little strange
given that a pandemic had just taken off
with many people becoming infected
but in the early days of uh of
developing this product this was a
significant challenge
few tests were available in early spring
2020
meaning that most covert 19 cases were
diagnosed with symptoms rather than a
test
designed to directly detect the virus of
those in use
many were also um homebrew
with uncertain quality or unknown
accuracy of results
so our clinical team made huge efforts
to procure samples that we had
sufficient confidence in
to use as reference material for both
test development
and test validation during the
diagnostic development um your gene
service lab
also came online for routine sars cop2
testing
initially this used this used a third
party c ibd product
where samples had the required consent
it then could then use these to support
chlorogenes
development by accessing those eligible
samples
when it came to selecting the type of
technology at qpcr
was the obvious choice though an
assessment was made early on as to
whether
we should utilize an alternative either
to avoid
clashes with the existing supply chain
or perhaps we could find some other
beneficial reason
in the end qpcr was becoming very
quickly established and it didn't make
sense to
go against the tide plus we also had
considerable experience in developing
qpcr
products within the business so this
little led into that particular
technology choice
basic features of the product also
needed to be established at the outset
as a business with an international
focus a key question was to define a
design
that would be suitable for for as many
global territories as we could possibly
achieve
and early on the design requirements
were not settled with guidelines
differing as to the number of targets
required
whether specific targets needed to be
included or
or just with very few guidelines at all
the product design also needed to factor
in technical
needs and limitations it seemed obvious
that a product that had at least two
viral targets
with uh was was the right choice because
with just one target
a risk of false negative results was
considered higher than when using
multiple targets fast turnaround time
was also an obvious need along with
just maintaining high overall accuracy
having selected qpcr as the technology
of choice
the range of platforms available across
thousands of laboratories worldwide
lent itself to a need to allow for
compatibility with a wide range of these
as possible while clarigene will be
validated as part of the civd
process on a defined instrument or
instruments we saw it as vital to allow
for laboratories looking to use the
product to be able to do so
on any existing pcr platform available
to them
particularly with the demand for qpcr
instruments also seemingly exceeding
capacity in a manner similar to the
reagents and plastics demands on supply
chain
a review was performed to understand
which fluorophores would enable
compatibility
and with the widest range of common
platforms
and this pointed us to a set of
fluorophores and using up to three
colour channels in total
uh covering viral detection as well as
any controls we decided to include
the table here is an example which
refers to a number of compatible
platforms though by no means all
the hazard of false negative results
will be potentially very significant
uh individuals could be given the go
ahead to interact with others or be in
whatever socially distanced way waves
acceptable
and meaning they could infect those they
come into contact with
therefore we considered it that false
negatives needed to be avoided at all
costs
so reviewing the workflow one obvious
route or false negatives
would be the failure of pcr across the
whole plate
this is easily remedied with a positive
control to be set up in each plate
if a positive run control fails then the
results must be discarded
similarly a no template control will be
used to account for
any potential false positive results so
an ntc
amplification would result in discarding
the plate
what the run controls don't account for
is
individual sample or reaction issues uh
bad samples whereby rna has degraded or
or are poorly set up individual well
on a run with both valid run controls uh
could still lead to false negative
results so the solution we
came to was to utilize an internal
control in every well
and one that requires the successful
reverse transcription and amplification
of a human rna target
therefore any poor collections
mishandling of samples or errors
in setup can therefore result in a
failure to detect
that internal control
the design of internal control was
therefore critical
and should control for all steps in the
process from sample collection through
to analysis
initially we tested a cdc design
and this worked well however after
reviewing the design
um closely it was clear that genomic dna
could also be amplified by that
particular primer and probe combination
meaning any contaminating dna would also
amplify
rendering the control ineffective for
reverse transcription
so we put together a new design that
would span the exon one and two boundary
of the
rpp30 gene and confirm the absence of
amplification
from genomic dna also observing
amplification from an
rna a human rna sample
with one of the three color channels
used for the internal control
the assay design then allowed for two
sarskov
ii viral targets this was considered to
meet the need for reducing false
negative risk
as two targets would require the
unlikely sporadic failure of two
amplifications
um particularly as the positive control
would
positive internal control result would
have to but it would have to fail
in combination um looking at the targets
to utilize we both
reviewed primary probe designs available
online
as well as looking at internally
designed sequences but the
goal was not to design a completely
unique and bespoke
primary probe design it was it was to
develop a high quality and effective
product so
the selection was made on that basis and
we selected designs of
the targeted regions and the n and e
genes
of these the engine target was expected
to be completely novel
to saskov 2 while the e gene target is
an area conserved from the original sars
virus
this absence of specificity of one of
the targets to the sars virus was not
considered likely to present any
challenges due to tarzan no longer being
in circulation
the while the analysis could itself be
tuned to allow for detection of both
targets
as required to give a positive result so
utilizing a conserve region was also
considered
to present a lower risk of mutations
occurring that would render the design
ineffective at detecting saskatchewan
and as we have seen since then products
detecting targets and the genes
encoding the spike proteins have faced
challenges due to
apparently higher rates of mutations in
these regions
with that assay design in place the
workflow and out and analysis was the
next item to lock down
so to talk you through the the product
and the assay and the setup involves
rna extraction from a sample arriving in
the lab
typically a nasopharyngeal swab and
before it then moves on to qrt pcr setup
each sampling control is set up in a
single reaction well
and the samples and run controls are all
then placed on
on the plate onto a qpcr instrument for
just over an hour
before the output file is available for
analysis
the analysis itself is straightforward
and uses
ct cutoffs so the positive and negative
control must be positive or the whole
run fails
or valid or the whole run fails and
samples negative for sas curve 2 must
give an internal control
result to be considered as valid and
have confidence in the result
the both size of two signals are
required for a positive
uh call and a single
size cop2 signal is considered as
an indeterminate result whether that's
with or without the
internal control amplifying and then no
signals from anything
is considered invalid
so with the assay design workflow
and analysis defined the team went on to
optimize the reaction
and reagent conditions typical
optimization robustness studies
and then we got to a fine unlocked
product so the next step from there is
then to demonstrate
the performance of the test across a
range of design verification validation
studies
as required for a ce ibd product
focusing here on two of these studies
data of particular interest was
considered to be the limit of detection
in clinical performance
across multiple products for f2
detection diagnostic detection are there
a range of lod claims quite
a wide range in some cases with a range
of methods
also used to generate the claims the one
of the things
that has been challenging is the absence
of a consistent standard
means that lod claims are not simply
defined by the product
but they are also defined by the sample
used to generate the data in the claims
so for example an over estimate or an
underestimate of the copies per
volume per microliter for instance
content from a standard manufacturer
would in turn then skew lod claims for
their products that
is using it time and care was taken
by the clara gene development team to
obtain a reliable standard
whereby we had confidence in the number
of copies per microliter
ultimately we were able to demonstrate
quite a low lod
successfully of the five viral copies
per
individual qpcr reaction
clinical performance was assessed using
a set of
samples with gold standard reference
data of these 100
detection was observed with no false
positive results
to support the in-house study an
independent
assessment was of the clarigene product
was also performed
and uh this also showed 100 detection of
positive cases with a with a very low
positive rate um the gold standard
itself was uh
another size cop2 diagnostic so the the
false positive result few that we saw uh
could have either been true false
positives or simply that clarogen is a
more
sensible sensitive uh assay and
detected real positives at low
concentration but the data
is presented as we see it and it shows
excellent results
it's successful design validation
alongside an effective
transfer to product operations ensured
that the cibd status of the product was
achieved at fast pace
with the clarigene sars kov2 ibd asset
ac marked
the next step was to get it in use
supporting the fight against the
pandemic
the obvious role out was to european
health service lab in manchester
and this provided an immediate impact
initially with
private partnerships that enabled people
to go into their workplaces in the
knowledge that they and their colleagues
were coping free
implementing the test in the service lab
enabled us to quickly see
that the launch test was reliable and
robust in a high throughput environment
the rollout was efficient with the lab
able to use the clarogene product in
place of a third-party test
that they had been using prior to
clarigence market
they were also able to automate the pcr
setup process in a short time frame
and in partnership with the software
development team at eurogene
developed software that was there to
manage the
testing process and tracking of sample
information
which was also developed and implemented
in combination this delivered a highly
effective
automated and scalable sars cough ii
diagnostic testing system
in our laboratory laboratories which
could then be potentially rolled out
elsewhere
so within a few months of launch in the
covid 19 diagnostic testing service the
lab was also approved for several
uk national testing purposes including
fit to fly test release and also a
sequencing service for viral
surveillance
demonstrating the high quality of both
the saskof2 test as well as that of the
service lab in manchester
and but designing validating and
launching a start cover ii product is
not the end of the story
uh all civd products require post-market
surveillance
though where clarigen differed from your
genes and many other products is the
rapid evolution of the virus
leading to mutations that seemingly
randomly appear throughout the genome
as mutations arise they could appear in
a location that degrades product
performance
and results in a primer probe
combination with reduced ability to
amplify in strains with that particular
mutation or mutations
or lose the ability to amplify
completely
the method of determining which strains
and mutations
uh called brick you monitor databases
such as
ncbi to determine the location of
mutations detected in the viral strains
from there any mutations found to be
located within
clarigene primer or probe locations will
be tested in the laboratory
fast and simple test is performed
whereby dna template containing the
mutation or mutations
will be tested alongside a wild type
template sequence and the ct values
compared
so as an example here we have uh
tested a mutation um and showing an
amplification plot so this is for
showing mean ct values for wild type and
s235f variants of the
b117 lineage which is often referred to
the uk variant
and testing was performed for wild type
and mutant
s235 samples at two different simulated
viral load
that 100 times lod and 10 times lod
the ct values are virtually identical
and this illustrates that there is no
significant difference in performance
for the clarigen assay
and with either the wild type of s235
sequences with both detection rate of
100
uh of 100 in both the different lod
values it's possible at any test
um at some point and a strain will
emerge
where the mutation does impact the assay
um many such mutations
have been found across the stars cov2
genome and other tests in the market
have found certain strains problematic
highlighting this need for constant
monitoring
so hence why we see it is also important
that we have backup prime and probe
combinations
and can plan to implement these into the
product
should the need ever arise the regular
monitoring of
sars cover 2 mutations supports making
this feasible
as it improves the chance that we would
identify any such problematic
mutations before that strain takes hold
in a population
so this takes us through where we are
today and so what have we learned
that developing and ensuring the supply
of
materials for a diagnostic athlete
rapidly during a pandemic is
very challenging it's getting the
key design decisions right early on is a
key focus
and as is getting the supply chain right
so always
key concerns but even more so during
this time and what we've achieved
we have a robust diagnostic product on
the market
and which has secure supplies and
materials for high volume manufacture
and where do we go in the future um well
that's something that we do regularly
review
um considering the sars cup to market
and where that will go
as well as now we've learned a little
about infectious diseases perhaps
further involvement in the diagnosis
diagnosis of other
infectious diseases and
that brings me to the end of this
presentation and before i finish
i'd like to give my thanks to the yogin
team
involved in clarigen in all capacities
it's been a huge effort from everyone
involved
and i'd also like to thank you for thank
you all for taking the time today to
listen to this presentation
i hope you found it valuable and i'm
grateful for the opportunity to talk
about
cara jean's pandemic diagnostic story